you can leave the weapons or leave the
station your choice please make it now
who are you I'm the one giving you the
choice I don't think anybody can really
deal with it I think we're sort of
trying to do business as usual the last
day today is a little heightened a
little you can you can feel it in the
air
I guess the feeling would be mellow you
know someone said to me uh oh they were
so sorry our show got cancelled and I
said seven years you consider seven
years a cancellation yeah it's been
pretty mellow like like a family reunion
were you at the end of a family a great
family reunion for the people who who
tuned in and and and and got it who who
saw what this particular Star Trek was
about and why it was different those
very passionate followers I think
there's going to be a real period of
grieving I can feel it already I read it
on the internet and I'm gonna be very
interested to see their reaction to the
final two hours because I don't suppose
you can please all of the people all of
the time there will be some people who
might be disappointed but overall I
think they're gonna be thrilled I mean
it's just not often that you get a
chance they're not that many shows that
get a chance to write their own finale
you know I mean it happens of course but
and we're very lucky that we knew and so
there's a sense of closure and a kind of
completion I don't know I don't know
seven years I did another show Benson
Randa for a long time too and even when
you do a long run of a Broadway show a
musical or something it's like there's
that Oh what time it's six o'clock in
the morning I should be in makeup
that'll hang on for a while and other
things will come along and the river of
life will flow
[Music]